mucho entusiasmo aquí en las calles de
París una gran multitud como puedes ver
a mis espaldas este es ya el inicio del
cortejo que empezó en La Explanada de
los inválidos y va a llegar hasta la
plaza de Italia hemos visto muchos
jóvenes volcados a las calles hoy hemos
conversado con varias personas nos llama
la atención el entusiasmo Pudiera Decir
la alegría que se ha expresado aquí con
música consignas y cantos conversamos
con una informática Parisina nos decía
que es muy fácil
transformar toda la ira contra el
gobierno en acciones violentas que el
desafío realmente es convertir esa ira
en lo que está sucediendo aquí en las
calles música alegría una forma cívica
de demostrar su oposición a la reforma
de pensiones como aquí en París otra en
otras trescientas
370 acciones se están desarrollando en
este momento en todo el territorio
francés espera entre 600.000 y 800.000
personas volcadas a las calles estas
acciones que hemos aquí hoy son
necesarias también para los sindicatos
porque necesitan atraer a las personas
necesitan mantener Arriba ese poder de
convocatoria y precisamente sobre ese
asunto hablamos con una responsable
sindical hace apenas unos minutos
escuchemos lo que vas a suceder es que
si el gobierno No no va atrás los
manifestantes está un poco Vamos a
continuar y estar en la calle y hacer
manifestaciones toda la población está
en esta contra este reforma y el
gobierno tiene que escuchar y tiene que
que retirar su reforma no hay otra cosa
posible
la única esperanza para derogar la
reforma de pensiones radica ahora en el
consejo constitucional que la semana
próxima deberá emitir un veredicto sobre
la constitucionalidad de la Reforma de
pensiones no hay grandes expectativas se
estima que quizás se censura en algunos
artículos de ese texto pero no su núcleo
es decir la edad de jubilación a los 64
años también el consejo constitucional
deberá emitir un veredicto sobre la
viabilidad de El referendo de iniciativa
compartida que pudiera someter a
votación popular la aplicación de la
Reforma de pensiones